invité de 5 à 10 ce matin olivier
bérisson le président du tout nouveau
mouvement politique qui s'appelle mon
nous bonjour olivier bérisson balcon
joue bel bon joue alors avec nous vous
voulez mettre l'humain au centre du
développement politique économique
culturelle et sociale de la martinique
exactement
et ça éviterait billets des problèmes
que nous avons à gérer aujourd'hui est
ce que chaque fois qu'on ne prenne une
décision la personne humaine est
respectée en sachant que la personne
humaine est le reflet de la terre de
l'eau et de lait que nous sur laquelle
nous comptons pour vivre à l'eau si nous
polluons saturn pour notre corps chez
nous pour lyon c'est terne ou pour une
autre cause chaque fois est ce qu'il est
envisageable deux fois le développement
autrement que par les lobbys et par les
industries qui nous occupe et puis nous
pouvons nous faire confiance à une
société qui a créé la déshumanisation
pour nous expliquer l'humanisation c'est
au vaste programme c'est ce qu'ils
appellent changement de mentalité au
changement de société
mon monde est un mouvement utopiste
alors il paraît qu'il faut une autre
pivot fondatrice eaux-vives mais non pas
du tout puisque nous sommes dans le
concret nous voyons qu on n a pas
respecté la personne humaine
nous voyons les conséquences aujourd'hui
un véritable génocide organisé en
martinique et nous a et les jeunes le
savent de quoi ils parlent
ils partent ils foutent le camp donc
nous avons un une île qui en tient non
seulement de vieillir et de ceux des
publi on sait qu'un pays qui se dépeuple
est un pays qui va mourir ce qu'est ce
que nous voulons pour notre pays nous
allons continuer à faire nous quand nous
allons descendre dans la rue pour des
emplois aidés à 600 euros et ne pas
descendre dans la rue pour notre santé
ne pas se mobiliser pour notre centre et
que pensez vous justement de ce silence
assourdissant
en ce moment des élus concernant le
scandale du chlordécone
je pense qu'ils sont plus reconnus c'est
à dire à un moment donné soit les
nanoparticules ont déjà mangé le cerveau
parce que je ne trouve pas d'excusés
mais d'après me demande s'il n'y a pas
un problème de santé publique
chez nous et lui envoie qui vient des
môles peut-être que j'étais moins
atteints et pas de bananes mais il ya
non simplement pour dire qu'il ya un
problème
aujourd'hui ils sont frileux mais bien
sûr puisque il y a aujourd'hui des
accointances avec ces lobbys s'il faut
le dire avec ses becker avec l'état
celui-là à sa fiche à hull à son son
coussin j'ai eu là que c'était à qui
embauchait celui là c'est les
partenariats et ses financements on voit
par exemple pour i'll be your man qui
finance des clubs sportifs et cetera qui
financent même démarche contre le cancer
dont on est il claque on simplifie ne
les mange c'est exactement ça on à
mcdonald's fait la même chose donc on a
en a exactement un problème de cap et de
légitimité et surtout vous ne
reconnaissez pas la légitimité des élus
c'est pas moi regardez le taux
d'abstention au regard des lettres
d'intention il ya un problème
aujourd'hui leurs élèves et jacques
martin et kaka diogo ça si ma femme
était en même temps à travers ces
politicards caffari est bas mais ça veut
dire qu'ils ne croient plus à ceux qui
organisent la société pour eu
aujourd'hui il faut oublier bernard l
et je vais vous dire quelque chose je
vais pas le risque qu'un de dieu quelque
chose il faut y mettre de la
spiritualité et après on va me dire est
ce que c'est une secte non aujourd'hui
les fêtes patronales s'organiser comment
votre calendrier d organiser comment
donc aujourd'hui à bien le lait cru mais
a besoin de croire quelque chose à quoi
quoi que nous savons nous quelles sont
nos origines
pourquoi les européens nous ont mis en
esclavage parce que nous avions nous
étions for women c'est enfin une cette
spiritualité en politique c'est pas ces
pannes ou des non plus on ne se fait pas
comme ça mais vous savez il y avait
quelque chose derrière mais bien un bien
derrière simplement le respect de la
personne humaine
vous avez besoin de spiritualité bons
saints et bien sûr bien sûr il faut
comprendre que jack nous devons vivre en
communion avec notre environnement comme
avis votre communion
si vous savez que vous êtes un
représentant de la mangrove que vous
êtes un représentant de la terre que
vous êtes en bois représentant de loups
comme vous êtes un représentant de l'oea
est ce que vous savez que ce que vous
faites à votre corps si la même chose
que vous faites à votre environnement
magna fait plus les oxymores afrique au
manioc pas fait picot simon n'ont en
effet pu les restes
moi j'ai envie de vous dire qu'il ya
aussi ce qu'on appelle la séparation des
pouvoirs de l'état entre l'état et le
religieux
oui la justice ne sait pas on parle
aussi de laïcité ça vous parle pas ça
vous l'entendez pas ça mais écoutez ma
expliquez moi pourquoi le cas lundi
aujourd'hui de toutes les fêtes est
basée sur la religion catholique
puisqu'il ya une séparation
expliquez-moi pourquoi toutes les fêtes
patronales de martinique sont liées
justement un calendrier toutes les mères
qui font une fête patronale
voilà mais ce qui est au coin bio pas qu
il ajouté exprimant la séparation donc
aujourd'hui il faut que les choses c'est
une hypocrisie
oui à une hypocrisie même la séparation
entre l'état la justice une hypocrisie
ne vois qui nomme les juges qui nomme le
parquet et d'ailleurs les décisions de
justice qui sont prises hommes en
tunique sur célé la france moi et
hôpitaux monsieur philip powers par
exemple les héros c'est quand même un
gage de j'ai pas de neutralité de
respect des droits notamment jettent ou
non et la martinique annoncé a été
goudronnée moon on note que d'avoir
discours et les martiniquais et
d'ailleurs même pas les meetings le
peuple du monde aujourd'hui c'est très
bien que kim qui tient les manettes et
s'est arrêté pour zéro problème très
clairement aujourd'hui pourquoi lui et
associations le cour des comptes d'après
vous pourquoi la socama qui est en
justice depuis 2007 n'a pas déposé de
dossier de connexité la paoute nous
avons nous sommes en train de regarder
comment attaquer au pénal ceux qui ont
acheté les stocks
monsieur de la gamme en 1981 donc on va
regarder ça on va regarder comment ta
copine à monsieur guy lordinot on va
regarder comme attaque au final monsieur
roy sont tues tu as dû attaquer
directement les individus parce que des
personnes ont décidé de la
déshumanisation de la martinique
qu'est ce qui n'est pas si vous avez été
président de l'asso damas et vous avez
démissionné qu'est ce qui n'était pas
possible
hier avec la super mamie serait possible
avec nous aujourd'hui parce que les
décisions général sont prises finalement
par la politique
alors je dis bien pas par les
politiciens
c'est un acte politique qui organise la
société aujourd'hui il ya des radios
libres
aujourd'hui vous avez une certaine
liberté d'expression c était décision
politique
donc aujourd'hui ce que nous disons
c'est que des militants joue niveau se
mouiller sur le terrain vaut prendre des
cours et vont se mettre face aux forces
de l'ordre alors que finalement des
politiques qui justement sont les
tenants et les aboutissants ne font rien
et pour les voir faire quelques motions
un petit courrier lisbonne juste comme
ça vous êtes en train de décrire
question soit préservé vous donc non
soyons sérieux
à part quelques uns mais ils sont trop
rares donc aujourd'hui il faut one
nouvellement et non pas dans l'opacité
de fans ou mais dans la luminosité de ce
que nous sommes en étant fiers de ce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui nous devra
affirmer le fait martiniquais une bonne
fois pour toutes nous devons affirmer le
feu martiniquais il ya des espaces
d'exposition pour sa hauteur de se
cacher des eaux de dieu c'est le préfet
c'est l'état nous ne nous avons une
responsabilité nous mentent et des
responsabilités en eau a subi six autres
ou pas loin c est lui à modern appel à
la mobilisation contre le chlordécone
portal biomatériaux radio quand même à
jamais tandis qu'on ne veut pas faire la
paix avec le parcours sera pas d'y
revenir
mais bien sûr par contre tu vas faire un
appel pour venir le défendre pour la
faire d'une part hot ou bien il y aura
fait appel pour les emplois aidés à 600
euros par compte
il y avait cinq emplois durables aux
lecteurs de cuari veille on a fait venir
cycle personnes venant de l'hexagone ne
connaissant rien va placer des personnes
martiniquaise lorsque vous envoyez vos
enfants faire des études
et puis qu'ils ne peuvent pas trouver de
poste ou bien lorsque vous embaucher à
la tête du site et du site du tcsp une
personne ingénieur en agriculture mais
un problème est qu'on respecte la
personne humaine est ce qu'on respecte
la personne qui a fait des études
est-ce qu'on a place là où elle doit
être placée au camp puisque arrivée des
as par exemple vous aviez par exemple un
informaticien responsable du du parc
informatique
car un diplôme de félonie alors parce
que tu as écouté ta parce que c'était
une fois arrêté ça le clientélisme il
faut arrêter ça vous avez aussi comme
slogan c'est mon petit café pays acp
avec les couleurs rouge vert noir ce
sont les couleurs du drapeau
martiniquais que vous revendiquez plus
que ça même les couleurs du drapeau
martiniquais ont des origines spirituel
importante plus que ça le vert c'est
l'univers le cosmos le noir c'est
l'humanité dans son sens originel du mou
et le rouge si le lien entre tout ce qui
nous entoure cela dieu cet univers-là et
l'humanité maintenant comment on fait
est ce qu'on a envie de ressembler à
certains pays
cette france à ces occidentaux qui
polluent qui tue qui exploite et c est
ce que des mots comme exploitation ne
devrait pas disparaître de notre
vocabulaire trois tâches agricoles pas
bon ferme avicole
j'ai entendu ce matin en europe en otage
on va exploiter ceci seul on utilise un
moule en somme c'est une énergie un mot
quand je dis allez vous hisser une
énergie connaît des oliviers c'est une
énergie qui m'a dit je t'aime c'est un
energy team a dit mme accueille quelque
chose dans l'énergie un bandage
est-ce que vous pensez que ça ne tue pas
choqué quand vous avez ce type de
discours j'espère bien mais j'espère
bien il faut renouveler il faut faire
autre chose a lancé quoi on fait
exactement les mêmes choses en mettant
des rustines sur des champs de pouilly
mais il faut faire autre chose il faut
au moins proposer autre chose mais
surtout ma cave pour poser sa marque
attendant la ville
vous allez vous présenter y aura des
candidats aux prochaines élections de
moon danger par municipal ou d'une liste
à la collectivité
nous sommes en train de préparer des
militants de la cause martiniquaise et
qui comprennent toute la philosophie
donc on verra si on sera présent lors
des prochaines échéances tout ce qu'il
est l'éclair comme ont en tout cas fait
entendre sa voix d'une manière ou d'une
autre vous étiez proche quand même deux
2 nous paie plat de marcelin nadeau
pourquoi ne pas rejoindre nous paie plat
je reste proche de mentionner seulement
la démocratie participative à
l'européenne me parlez est une illusion
vous ne croyez pas non pourtant son dit
que c'est le peuple pour le peuple
gouverner avec le peuple et prendre des
décisions